[Music]
now like most americans i was glued to
the news this week watching that insane
series of events unfold a mob of trump
supporting terrorists stormed the u.s
capitol on wednesday in an effort to
overturn a fair and legal election and
subvert democracy it has honestly been a
lot to take in and my personal feelings
have ranged from rage to devastation to
embarrassment but the largest takeaway
for me feels too important to put into
words so i wanted to put it in a song
[Music]
least it wasn't
[Music]
that's right black people got to sit
this one out and just watch it from the
sidelines and frankly i love that for us
buckingham palace announced that queen
elizabeth ii and prince philip received
the coronavirus vaccine so now all they
have to worry about is a stiff breeze
joe biden was sworn in this week as the
46th president of the united states
that's right it's out with the old and
in with the elderly
vice president kamala harris on
wednesday became the first female black
and asian-american person to hold the
office making her the first vice
president who i know has been to a sally
beauty supply
senator bernie sanders office has
released a sweatshirt featuring the
popular photo of him at the inauguration
it's the perfect gift for that special
someone who doesn't know when a joke is
over now you probably read a bunch of
headlines over the past two weeks about
this fiasco that's going on between
people on reddit and some hedge funds
that have been taking advantage of the
gamestop stock and you know
i would love to cover it on the show but
the truth is that i don't fully
understand what's going on oh
finally my time to shine i understand it
completely uh you want me to explain
you can try but i've been reading
articles and watching videos about it
for two weeks the second my brain tries
to process anything about the stock
market i just shut down completely and
start thinking about some other nonsense
now friends it's black history month and
you know what that means america is
lying about how much we loved malcolm x
martin luther king jr and rosa parks but
black people i'm here to tell you that
you don't have to be the leader of a
movement a pop star or a president to be
worthy of acknowledgement this month or
ever new york city's movie theaters will
reopen next month at 25 percent capacity
also known as a great crowd for an
improv show toy company hasbro received
backlash last week after they announced
that they're dropping the mister from
their popular mr potato head playset in
an effort to be more inclusive but if
you ask me that's too inclusive because
if there's one thing i know about
potatoes it's
[Music]
potatoes are boys they have
and balls potatoes can't be girls cause
they don't hang out in mall if you think
veggies can't be gendered then you have
failed spuds have a gender and that
gender is male
during a recent interview with oprah
duchess meghan markle revealed that she
and prince harry were secretly married
three days before the royal wedding
which begs the question
who was it that was concerned about how
dark his skin will be
they better make with her name i swear
to goodness how dark will it be
how dark will the baby will it be
dark or will it be dark dark will it be
darker
here's some stuff to look forward to
going to a concert and becoming
temporary best friends with the
strangers next to you for the duration
of the concert as you all sing at the
top of your lungs
but you can't sing at the top of your
lungs if your lungs are filled with
fluids so wear a mask
locking eyes with your best friend at
your other best friend's wedding when
the pastor says if anyone here has a
reason why this couple shouldn't be
married because y'all know some [ __ ]
but that beautiful moment of friendship
may never happen if you catch coven and
die because you didn't want to wear a
mess to pick up your take out order from
tgi fridays mediocre apps are not worth
it the creators of sesame street
introduced two new black muppets this
week to help facilitate discussions of
racism and black identity which must
have been a bummer for the new black
muppets
can we just do counting
oh
oh re relive the drama
all right s is for systemic racism
[Laughter]
in order to promote vaccinations krispy
kreme announced that they'll be giving
out a free donut to anyone who shows
their full vaccine card for the rest of
the year
still not going to take it well why not
i don't trust it my uncle got the
vaccine he still died
of covid
no i got hit by a car but still a jury
this week found former minneapolis
police officer derek shovin guilty on
all three charges in the murder trial of
george floyd and it was as simple as one
two
three
four five
six seven eight 9 10 11 12 13. the
academy awards were on sunday and
actress glenn close lost her eighth
oscar nomination but she did win a
source award a b-e-t award and an naacp
image award
[Applause]
okay
the woman did the book the fda announced
plans to ban flavored cigars in order to
help reduce quote youth initiation which
is too bad because frankly there's
nothing cuter than this
nasa announced recently that they will
be landing the first person of color on
the moon first i know right can you
believe that there are still firsts out
there for people of color i can but it's
depressing republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor green came under fire
this week after a video surfaced of her
verbally harassing representative
alexandria ocasio-cortez's staff back in
2019 before green was in congress
accompanied by a few friends green
yelled at ocasio-cortez's staff through
the mail slot in her office door and
dared the congresswoman to come out and
face her see for yourself alexandria
ocasio-cortez i'm an american citizen i
pay your salary for the taxes that you
collect from me through the irs you need
to stop being a baby and stop locking
your door and come out and face the
american citizens that you serve if you
want to be a big girl you need to get
rid of your diaper and come out and be
able to talk to the american citizens
instead of just having to use a flap
guess what
you can't stand there forever
can you come out and play
wow
that is truly terrifying
the senate this week passed a bipartisan
bill to promote new technologies
including artificial intelligence and
robotics
what
could
go
wrong
president biden and russian president
vladimir putin met for a summit in
geneva this week and there was only one
thing on their agenda
according to new reports the nypd is
expected to to exceed its overtime
budget for the year by over 160 million
dollars
damn if they keep that up those police
are going to defund themselves
new york governor andrew cuomo resigned
this week and then immediately leaned in
for a goodbye kiss
that's right andrew cuomo resigned this
week amid sexual harassment allegations
and it's been a remarkable fall from
grace a year ago people were buying
merch with his face on it hell i even
got carried away and i bought a t-shirt
now what am i supposed to do with this
what am i going to do with this
what am i going to do with this
good question
oh i know get mom written under it and
tell people you have an ugly mom oh
that's that's a good idea yeah thanks
after recently issuing an executive
order prohibiting mass mandates texas
governor greg abbott announced this week
that he had tested positive for the
coronavirus
even worse he announced it right into a
reporter's mouth
hey hey huh come here yeah come here huh
yeah
my mouth was open it was national senior
citizens day was this week celebrate by
asking a senior citizen what their plan
is for leaving afghanistan
what is it texas's new abortion law the
law that went into effect on september
1st and
it it makes abortion illegal in the
state after six weeks opponents to the
bill have protested using the phrase my
body my choice but was it ever according
to a new poll 63 percent of americans
believe employees should receive paid
time off to get the coronavirus vaccine
said amazon workers paid time what now
last weekend more than 126 000 gallons
of oil was spilled into the pacific
ocean in southern california efforts to
undo this damage are going to
no
sorry
no i don't want to do anything about
this yeah i don't want to think about
this at all
because you see
some news gives me the roots
[Music]
some news makes me feel pissed
but some news is just so bad
baby i pretend it doesn't exist columbus
day was this week
and it is just crazy that we still
celebrate columbus because everybody
knows
columbus was a
[ __ ] was a [ __ ]
[Applause]
columbus sailed the ocean blue
his dumb ass got lost in 1492.
we still celebrate him though we know
what he did
enslaved and killed people
women and kids in an attempt to distance
themselves from their negative public
image facebook announced yesterday that
they are changing their name so be sure
to check out new face who dis book
while president biden was in europe this
week let's go brandon
oh i'm sorry what was that
i said
i said let's go brandon oh who's brandon
you don't know no
hilarious okay so there was this nascar
race last month where a guy named
brandon won and the whole crowd started
chanting something and the reporter who
was interviewing him thought they were
chanting let's go brandon
but really
they were chanting
joe biden
so now whenever conservatives want to
really stick it to liberals they say
let's go brandon
huh oh sorry i tuned out after you said
nascar race but
i'm glad you're having fun and good luck
to brandon whoever that is let's go
brandon
oh my god she said it i got her to say
it oh my god this is incredible this is
definitely going viral okay cool moving
on it's time for our next segment joe
biden
wait what during the recent u.n climate
summit in scotland president biden
reportedly let out a quote long loud
fart in front of britain's duchess
camilla parker bowles now that is a real
thing that really happened after
participating in the capitol riots the
so-called qnan shaman was sentenced this
week to 41 months in prison he was
judged by a jury of his peers
even they were like
is
i like it when white supremacists face
consequences nope yeah
before being hideous yeah
sang a song by that title i don't regret
it before being sentenced this week over
his participation in the capital riots
the so-called q anon shaman reportedly
quoted the film the shawshank redemption
and so did the judge when he said guilty
this group is dangerous and
anti-american but also
can we talk about their complete lack of
rhythm look at this
oh what is happening what are you doing
what are these people stepping on the
ones and sevens that is the sloppiest
beat i have ever heard in my life it
sounds like he picked up the sticks and
then just dropped them on the drums
the sounds they made are the sound
that they're going with
these guys they were protesting america
and across the street a group of
metronomes was protesting them
this was great should we do it again
sometime
all right
see you later alligators
[Applause]
[Music]
you